bonsoir poser dorado merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt français ce que
clairement pedro sanchez ou bien team de
faire un coup politique susceptible de
le maintenir encore un peu plus son
pouvoir
alors un coup politique certainement
depuis plusieurs semaines gouvernements
des pays ressenti investi les
informations laissant entendre que cette
grâce allait arriver il est arrivé comme
l'a indiqué votre correspondante
c'est matin en conseil des ministres est
il susceptible de continuer dans le
gouvernement ça par contre c'est
beaucoup plus dur à dire mais tout
simplement parce que déjà les derniers
sondages depuis plusieurs mois montre un
resserrement entre le parti socialiste
au pouvoir et le parti populaire
conservateur donc dans l'opposition mais
aussi parce que c'est des décisions mais
même si le président du gouvernement a
parlé d du temps du dialogue le temps
des l'harmonie entre tous les espagnols
un rapprochement entre la catalogne et
le reste de l'espagne même si la parle
de ça la réalité et est qu'aujourd'hui
et la fracture elle est toujours là
beaucoup beaucoup d'espagnols sont
contre cette décision de grâce aux
indépendantistes qui a été condamné par
le tribunal suprême après la tentation
de d'indépendance et de sédition mais la
réalité est aussi qu effectivement même
enceinte du parti socialiste
cette décision ne fait pas l'unanimité
mais en tout cas pedro saint tite a eu
le courage d prendre cette décision
maintenant effectivement on va voir dans
les prochaines semaines si cette table
de dialogue entre l'espagne et le
gouvernement catalan va donner et
quelque chose mais on tout état à des
causes c'est un pari risqué à une sortie
incertaine clairement luis pedro 76
en tout cas il fait passer cette idée
officiel indique cette grâces était la
meilleure décision pour l'espagne le
vivre ensemble et la constitution
espagnole c'est quoi ça c'est l'essai
la communication où il ya un fond de
vérité alors il ya forcément un fond de
vérité puisqu'il a décidé de prendre
cette mesure mais moi j'ai juste rappelé
qu'il était là était la décision du
tribunal suprême
il y a quelques semaines le tribunal
suprême a été consulté par rapport à
cette grâce et la décision du elf à
l'avis du tribunal suprême c'est d'être
que c'était grâce était mal venu parce
qu' elle ne n'avais pas aucune des trois
conditions qui sont nécessaires pour une
grâce c'est à dire une utilité publique
le président du gouvernement défend que
cette année grâce d'utilité publique
ce n'est pas l'avis du tribunal suprême
et qui une une blessure d équité le
tribunal suprême trouvé qu'il n'y avait
pas d' équité dont le fait de gracier et
des politiques qui avaient tenté et donc
dès qu'ils avaient été condamnés par le
délit d'aidé sédition et le tribunal
suprême
entendez aussi qu'il n'y avait pas de
justice qui est de la troisième
condition donc vous voyez on tout état
en tout état de cause l'espagne est
encore aujourd'hui donc assez difficile
par rapport à 7 à cette décision
mais encore une fois c'est vrai c'est
une décision difficile à tenir
on sait parfaitement que avant l'été
dont les prochaines semaines voire de la
rentrée de septembre
il va y avoir un remaniement du
gouvernement espagnol par la part de la
part de dp deux centièmes tout
simplement parce que on est à mi mandat
et justement il va falloir réussir ce
que paie de sentiers propos savez que
celle de grâce parce que comment je vous
le dit tout à l'heure
la différence entre aujourd'hui entre
l'opposition et le parti socialiste crsr
et il n'est pas certain qu'il puisse
gagner et cette partie mais encore une
fois il fallait tenter quelque chose
pour commencer à nouveau le le dialogue
pedro sanchez l'a fait il partie de
l'espagne n'est pas d'accord mais ça
c'est les urnes qui diront s'il a eu ou
pas raison donc quelques années dont
deux ans exactement s'il va jusqu'au
terme de son mandat le nouveau président
et j'en ai
pendentif de catalogne père à gonesse
est considérée comme plutôt modéré est
ce que ça pourrait améliorer les
relations avec le gouvernement espagnol
et apaisée des choses clairement
je pense qu'effectivement ça pourrait
effectivement aidée il restait quand
même au corps je ne dirais pas un détail
mais vous savez il ya les neuf personnes
qui élèvent politiques qui ont été
graciées d'accord mais il ya encore cinq
garçons qui sont en fuite et notamment
carlos puis seulement l'ancien président
des deux gouvernement catalan pour qui
cette grâce n'est pas applicable parce
qu'il n'a pas été condamné donc
donc il ya ces dossiers au corps qui
reste donc ici très est très présente
mais c'est vrai qu'après aragonès est un
politique beaucoup plus conciliateur
beaucoup plus partisan du dialogue mais
en même temps il doit faire face à sa
coalition de gouvernement en catalogne à
l'intérieur de son propre gouvernement
donc il va vraiment pas aussi juif un
jouet est très fin avec pedro
essentielle pour pouvoir entamer le
dialogue ça sera dans quelques jours
dans quelques semaines puisque federer
n'est ce pas aller à marée de rencontrer
les perdrix se perdre s'inquiète mais
surtout dès la rentrée des vacances et
qu'il va falloir effectivement commencé
à montrer qu'il y à des avancées il
n'est pas trop de dire que cette cette
nouvelle entre 10 mai aventure entre la
catalogne et l'espagne est incertain je
vous le dit tout à l'heure mais encore
une fois il fallait faire quelque chose
puisque ont été denses à l'impasse des
puits effectivement la décision du
tribunal suprême des condamnés les
indépendantistes catalans dans le
gouvernement qui se dit ouvert à un vote
des catalans destiné à donner donc plus
d'autonomie
la région est ce que c'est pas un risque
que d'autres régions espagnoles
réclament les mêmes avantages on ouvre
en quelque sorte la boîte de pandore ce
n'est pas ça risque c'est une réalité
puisque l'espagne est un pays assez
décentralisé de que vous donner quelque
chose à une région les autres régions
vont vouloir avoir aussi le là même la
même chose
donc c'est pour ça que je vous disais il
va falloir jouer très fin qui est parce
que de l'autre côté de l'espagne que ce
soit en andalousie
que ce soit en galice que ce soit du
côté de madrid
donc des endroits où le parti socialiste
ne gouverne pas ils vont pas faire de
cadeau au gouvernement de pedros
inquiet et c'est vrai et c'est vrai que
cette situation peut devenir explosif si
que vous le dites cette boîte de pandore
est ouverte et qu'il n'y a pas des
gestes d'apaisement que ce soit du côté
de madrid où que ce soit du côté de
barcelone dans les prochains mois merci
juan arrosée à dorado journaliste
espagnole correspondant à paris merci
d'avoir été avec nous